and hip-hop is like you know he's gay
like bad news the people who fail in
life at the things that they want to do
they always give a reason or excuse an
excuse to why they can't do it sure you
could wake up and just pain every day
but like you gotta pay your bills a lot
of hip-hop is like really it just is
like real terrible like the the consumer
I do my best to treat everybody with the
same respect I treat you like I would
treat my garbage man or the president
he's an American rapper singer
songwriter and record producer his debut
studio album under pressure was released
in October of 2014 to critical success
under pressure debuted at number four on
the US Billboard 200 chart he's logic
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number six is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the to the end for some
special bonus clips
and hip-hop is like you know he's gay
like bad dude like you know to me like I
just why don't you like him you know
what he can rap he got a good story his
flows of cool for show I just don't like
him though like in it like so ignorant
it's crazy so like yeah years ago
you know them saying when I first got on
blogs and I'd be excited I read comments
but now it's just like there's no point
to recommit yeah don't read the cup I
don't read the cup yeah it's either too
it's either too positive which can lead
you to like the Pettit where it's too
negative which could make you try to
create music to get them to stop hating
on you it's like somebody being like
yeah he should rap like this he should
rap like that I don't like the way raps
and then the person changes up how they
rap to try to you know make that person
like them and then they're like may hand
even beat himself like after your tapes
so it's like you can't win this run
can't win no matter what you do right so
for me I don't listen to the hate I
don't listen to love too much I just you
know take it all in stride
like I love what I do and as long as I
can wake up every day and feel that I
feel like I'm doing right thing the law
of attraction to me is a very real thing
you speak it into existence you say it
and then you do it it's like this secret
to success or whatever the case may be I
think true truly and utterly the people
who fail in life at the things that they
want to do they always give a reason or
excuse an excuse to why they can't do it
you know I would but or I want to but I
can't because you know and there's
always this like at the end of the day
you just you have to do it I came from
nothing I came from section 8 household
welfare food stamps and you know
drug-addicted parents nothing and I'm
here today talking to you and I have so
much more to go and so much more to do
but I can like look in the mirror and
say like I've made it whatever the hell
that means see an automated and I did it
because I said I was gonna do it and I'm
gonna continue to do it I'm gonna act
I'm gonna write novels and books and
movies and you know I'm gonna do my best
to be the best husband and father I can
be and you know so there's so much more
but I'm gonna do it and I think that's
what it really comes down to don't ever
do anything just for the money because
if
do it just for the money you won't
you'll never be happy do what you love
because if you do what you love and you
wake up every day doing that it doesn't
matter because you'll be happy which i
think is I I think it's 100% truth to an
extent you know like you can sure you
could wake up and just pain every day
but like you got to pay your bills do
you know what I mean like there's a way
there's a way you got to do it so sure
waking up and painting every day but if
painting isn't paying your bills so it's
just like you know make a way for
painting to pay your bills you said I'm
saying maybe you paint for ad companies
or this or that on the side so then you
can pay whatever the hell you want
during that you know what I mean so just
whatever it is do what you love and
that's the biggest thing I've I've
that's that's my whole thing do what you
love it like you are a very friendly
person who's from a relatively tough
circumstance what made you that way
I think I like I truly believe that
you're a product of your environment you
know I'm saying so we had it really bad
and you know my sister's got pregnant
and my brothers were selling drugs and
he's and doing drugs and these are the
things that they saw and they went that
route you know I actually have a song on
the album where it's because I've talked
about my dogs my dad's drug abuse for
many years now and I really delve into
it on the album and one of the things
that I you know he called me and was
like you know I really wish he would
stop talking about that and I was like
well I wish you had been a father and
been there and I wish that you would
understand that by me writing this is
ten times better than me using those
same and drugs drugs and inflicting them
upon myself to get over it so maybe you
should like not be so selfish and
realise it right and be happy that my
way of dealing with its positive exactly
so but what I what I'm saying as far as
you know being a product of your
environment is where they may have
chosen a you know over the wrong path
per se you know I I saw it and it made
me kind of go in the right direction I
guess this is up to God not to sound
like cliche again but that's what that
is
but it's also up to you I mean you were
a kid who made that decision you know
I'm not gonna do it but I just believe
in honor and valor man like we live you
know this demographic like now I'm not
talking about the purists I'm not
talking about people like yourself but
like a lot of hip-hop is like really it
just it's like real terrible like the
consumer cuz all they care about is like
it's like it's almost I'd be more
you know legitimately acceptable if I
was you know six to black with dreads
and toted guns and then people would be
like oh he's a real rapper as opposed to
like carrying myself with grace and
speaking how I speak and not trying to
throw the accent on everything I'm like
you know I'm just me man and I think if
anything that's going to be more
authentic in the long run rather than
trying to pretend to be someone I'm not
I've gone through those same experiences
you know I was taught and cooked crack
in my kitchen at from 12:00 to you know
like in my teenage years to learn and
see what these things were about and
understand because they were going on in
my household but I don't glorify it I'm
not like yeah we cooking crack we've got
this I'm like damn why was I 12 years
old and my sister's baby daddy was
showing me how to cook crack like where
were my parents you know to me and in
explaining that stutters all the
negative experiences that I might have
gone through or whatever the case may be
built a much more positive person you
know what I mean cuz that's why I'm so
positive all the time I like to tell
people like you know I'll go on Twitter
and I'll say you know my whole motto
which is peace love and positivity
follow your dreams do what you love in
life whatever that might be and you know
I've been saying it for years
and it started with me telling myself
because nobody else was telling me
nobody was telling me to follow my
dreams or that I could do it or that I
could be somebody and then it ended up
me telling myself this in songs I ended
up telling millions of people that
listen to it which is which is really
crazy and and just always doing my best
to be a good person because when I first
started like imagine imagine going
somewhere and meeting somebody in the
industry and they're like walk past you
and don't even look you in the face or
talk to you or say hello and then then
you start to get a buzz but people still
aren't sure who you are and then it's
like oh this is logic he's got so-and-so
such amount of views on YouTube and
they're like oh what's up but it's like
it's like nah yo so so me I do my best
to treat everybody with the same respect
I treat you like I would treat my
garbage man or the president it's just
the saying it doesn't anybody do you
feel underrated as a rapper not as of
lately like which is crazy for a long
time and for years I was pissed so a
song on the album called buried alive
issues it's about that exactly you know
about like me kind of going how come he
gets this so-and-so cosine or how come
he gets that or how come they get that I
can tour the world I can sell out shows
I got fans I got this what the man's
like being angry you know I had a friend
tell me she basically said those same
people who have the cosines and have
this and have the looks are the same
people are going how come I got fans
like this dude how come I can't tell
where on my own how come I can't dislike
with them so I kind of put things in
perspective for me and let me go okay I
don't have it yet but if I keep fighting
I keep working hard and I keep staying
on this path it's gonna happen you know
and as of late was in the last few
months man just from you know like
releasing the singles and the music
videos and like this solid body of work
I've truly began to give what I deserve
so since my motto my whole motto is
peace love and positivity peace love and
positive it that's my home Otto and some
people like hate me they're like you war
hate negativity they'll say disgusting
things cool thing but that's just the
internet and I used to always just
people yeah listen if they're broken
inside oh yeah they're trying to drag
people down with that and I used to
wonder I would ask myself I would say
why do people hate I don't understand it
I don't understand how why would
somebody hate on me why would somebody
hate and then it clicked and I said I'll
never understand because I'm not a hater
I don't have a hater mentality I have a
winter mentality of lovers mentality I
get it so it's just like you know with
law of attraction or whatever you want
to call it like I don't do that I don't
use you know a lot of people say oh you
know I wish I could travel the world or
I wish I could do this with my life but
and as soon as I say but that's it they
destroyed it it's over I'm depressed a
but that's bullsh
you have to say I'm gonna I will you
know or before you know I mean I
remember when I was 7 years old before
they did the English dub of a Kyra I saw
it when I was a kid I didn't know what
it was it was terrifying disturbing and
very beautiful all at the same time and
then so when kind of digging into this
album I was like man that's that's where
I kind of really want to take it I want
to just be fully creative you know and
it's like man you know what like who
cares what's this what's that or if I
got to fit in with this person or that
person and I realize like all my fans
most of you [ __ ] don't fit in
with nobody and that's when they fit in
with everyone
so my planet you know to me like all the
fans so many people like like I watched
these fan submissions because you know
I'm doing this tour fan tour and they're
like your music is amazing but honestly
dude it's your message and the people
I've met because of your music and it's
like whoa that's crazy
that's what's the matters the most you
know my whole mentality has been just
like I don't give a [ __ ] like I don't
give a damn about nothing man I used to
care so much like what people thought
because I love this culture so I really
love this culture but his cultures also
really [ __ ] up so I was like you know
what okay like I'm just gonna be me I'm
gonna do me so when I when I told myself
I'm gonna create an album about anime in
space if I was like I'm gonna do it but
I'm gonna do it in a way where if you
don't give a damn about this you can
just skip it and enjoy the day without
okay that's a good start so I got a good
business idea I'm gonna trick logic into
using one of your beats and then you're
gonna blow up and everything's gonna be
set yeah so wait is this more like but
is it is this more like a like like
you're trying to set up your personal
brand via social media is that what
you're asking the best way to go about
that yeah so you're trying to become a
big producer you want to be Metro boomin
you want to go in that route yeah logic
my my advice here is interaction with
your peers and through that so say
there's other producers so there's
there's a bazillion producers out there
right so find some of your favorites or
some people that you would almost see as
competitors and collaborate if you work
with somebody else you guys are always
trying to outdo each other but it's such
a friendly competition that that their
listeners on their YouTube and their
Twitter are gonna find out that you guys
are working together and then they're
gonna want to hear what you're doing
with this guy or that guy and then
through that then other rappers are
gonna start to hear what you guys are
doing together or even individually and
then when I mess with you and then that
rapper might have you know two thousand
followers or five thousand five or
whatever the case may be so to be quite
honest I think it's especially in this
day and age for personal branding
there's two things there's one you
should you know do little vlogs and talk
about who you are and the things that
you like and the things you enjoy how do
you produce is it FL studio is it
Ableton do you use an MPC do you like
the keyboard all these things do
tutorials how to make
how did this how did that you you want
people to tune in and go I like this guy
so for everything I want I'm gonna come
to him whether I want to buy a beat
whether I want to learn how to make a
beat or whatever the case may be it
should be all about you you want to be
the you know what I mean so I would say
just have fun and and connect with
others that that are even better than
you and learn why they're better than
you and take their secrets and kick ass
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because life asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know what
your logics top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you and why which of the clips
resonated most with you leave it in the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Catherine pair
Catherine thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book if you guys
watching if you want to change that eye
shadow in a future video make sure to
get the book and email in your receipt
so we can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon
but this is what I want you to do you
mix up that Rubik's Cube oh extremely
bad hand it IED IED a mix it up
extremely bad now what I want you to do
is I'm gonna put on an instrumental okay
and you got a freestyle restate your
mind oh yeah okay so I might say some
crazy I don't know what I may be saying
but you got a freestyle while you're
doing that Rubik's Cube freestyle or you
can just give me something from the
album but I want your concentration to
be on lyrics as well okay as what's
going on with this room rub the tummy
kind of stuff who is mixing it up best
believe it yeah
alrighty pretty good that looks pretty
much right I'm looking at all
competition no my wife wants to put me I
think you should and I talked to Juicy J
and Juicy J was like I'll come and I'll
and I'll support you he's like yeah he's
like as long as I can get drunk I'll be
there here we go alright and we you know
what I don't even you could time him but
I'm not really going for time okay
I'm going for logic all right now you
got a you got a make sure that you
kicking lyrics why are you doing this
this is what we do not I give me the
next one give me the next about this
yeah
Oh check check oh yes yeah I like this
beep am here we go you ready uh-huh
here we go check it I'm about to spit
the vibe this is how we do it whether
it's that newer that try we always got
to keep it alive you know my vision and
tell it crazy the flow is never lazy see
I don't even know what I'm saying I'm
just faking Anna Barbados the second I
get it is crazy cuz she Jamaican me
crazy I don't know I'm just spitting
this rhyme I gotta spit it on time the
second I do it Strictly Come on my mind
they say they know the deal I always
keep it reeling yes I get it like that
this is how we do I got my first hat
that happy wife happy life not a flow is
never try if I got it get it like this
it's hella crazy nada the flow is never
lazy and it doesn't even make sense it
doesn't even matter
I'm just spitting at that random thought
it can't be taught this is how we do it
speaking of thoughts I can't fade these
holes where y'all been
we got going this is how we do it I
don't even know what I'm sayin I ain't
knowing I'm just keeping this I got this
Rubik's Cube it's got the loop and pause
on that we all on that and this is how
we do it when I Spit these rhymes it's
it's kind of crazy
oh no when y'all mess this rubik's cube
up see hold up hold up y'all rest it up
so I got a flip this around take it out
put it back in now I do the algorithm
real slick real smooth
this is how we do it like a criminal
flow so medicinal my stuff is heavily
medicated never eradicated they
evacuated the second I arrived on the
scene I spit in hella clean spit a hella
mean thought I had it for a second but I
didn't gotta bring it back this is like
it's really crazy when you spit it like
this I know my god don't really mess
this thing up go ahead hush it up y'all
mess it up I gotta bring it back y'all
was flipping it too hard with your
fingers I'm winging i'm lingering i got
it i'm singing them bringing them in and
this is how we do it let me begin i
would have solved it fast if y'all mess
it up but it's all good we gotta keep it
going shoutout took her up that West
Coast the holy the one and only the
Grail to spit a second I get it and I
prevail
that is right here watching movies to
freestyle never done